Today we are learning English with the unequaled
Lana del Rey and some of her most successful
songs! So whether or not you are a fan of her
music, if you watch this lesson until the end
you will learn how metaphors help you to build
your fluency. And my favorite part of this lesson
is that you will be able to put your listening
to the test with different activities! So we'll
jump into all that momentarily, but before we
do this is the only place on youtube where you
will understand fast speaking natives, without
getting lost, without missing the jokes and even
without subtitles. Just like Ana Vitoria who says
that thanks to our lessons she can understand 90
percent of movies without subtitles. So are you
ready to take your English to the next level? Then
join us! Hit the subscribe button and the bell
down below so that you don't miss a single lesson.
So as an English learner you've probably
already heard how songs can be a fun way
to improve your English. So if you
like to listen to music in English
but you're not so sure how to study with, them
then I highly recommend you check out this lesson
in which we teach you practical exercises
to use songs to speak more confidently!
By the way, do you get frustrated
when natives speak fast
and you can't understand? Do you want to
be able to comprehend your favorite songs,
movies and series? Well to be able to
do this you need to master three things:
vocabulary, pronunciation and cultural context.
We will help you to do all this in our three part
master class and you'll have a ton of fun
along the way! The best part is it's free!
So what are you waiting for? Sign up clicking
up here or down the description box below.
Alright! So now I have a quiz for you where you
will test your English listening with Lana del
Rey! And you know another great thing about
learning with songs is that they often offer
rich cultural references. Lana's songs
are absolutely full of American culture
and knowing about the culture is crucial if you
want to understand songs, laugh with the jokes
in your favorite series or relate to native
speakers. That is why over on our instagram
you can get a bonus lesson where you will
learn all about American culture with
Lana! So be sure to check that
out after you finish the quiz.
So if you speak English with the rhythm of your
native language, it can make you sound a little
bit unnatural. Songs tend to exaggerate the
rhythm of the language so they can be a great
tool to help you to practice speaking English with
the correct rhythm and flow while stressing words
correctly. Of course because of the melody in
some songs there might be a slight change in the
pronunciation. This is however the exception so it
should not scare you away from learning with song.